hey guys it's Jonah here you're probably
watching this video because you would
like to break your bad habits habits run
our daily life almost everything we do
is have it based we have those good
habits which are great but we all have
those bad habits which we want to break
whether it's overeating stop - munching
quit smoking quit drinking or spending
less time online so I'm going to get
straight into it I'm going to share with
you 10 effective and practical steps you
can take right now to break up bad
habits and to achieve your life and
fitness goals first you got to
understand your habits ignoring your bad
habits and wishing that they would just
go away will not work you've got to be
aware of your bad habits and then take
the step to break it so every habit
follows the same three-step pattern the
trigger what triggers you to gain the
reward you want the routine which is a
physical or emotional action you take to
gain the reward and the reward the
satisfaction you hope to get following
the routine all habits have thoughts and
actions that take place beforehand so
the key is to keep track of these
patterns for you to understand your bad
habits so take notice and take notes for
at least a couple of weeks for you to
really nail down what are your bad
habits the golden rule of habit change
is to pair the same trigger with the
same reward and only change the action
in the middle so for instance the
trigger is stress and the reward is to
calm yourself down the action in the
middle is the habit of mindless munching
we want to change the action in the
middle to a healthier habit for example
drinking a warm cup of green tea which
can help with relaxation or going for a
long walk you won't instantly find a new
healthier habit to replace the old habit
this will take time and even trials
before you can see permanent change the
next step is to visualize your new
lifestyle in order to replace your bad
habits with new habits you got to first
think and visualize your new lifestyle
and how that would make you feel this
will be your inner motive
to keep pushing you forward for you to
achieve your goals for example if I quit
smoking I'm going to have more energy
more money and better health for my kids
if I stop eating junk foods and choose
healthier options I'm going to start
losing weight my clothes will fit better
and I'm going to feel fabulous on my
wedding day
visualize your new lifestyle not just
once but start your day with positive
affirmations and this will also serve as
a daily reminder the third step is stop
focusing on what you're not going to do
instead focus on what you are going to
do we tend to set and negative goals and
focus on the things we're not going to
do for instance I'm not going to eat
junk foods I'm not going to smoke I'm
not going to binge anymore instead of
focusing on what you're not going to do
and fight against it the idea is to
focus on your new positive habits and
the things you are going to do I'm going
to come more often and eat home I'm
going to exercise three times weekly I'm
going to chew on gum when I have the
urge to smoke next focus on small
achievable goals so the idea is not a
get rid of your bad habit the next day
I'm sure you have tried it and probably
failed at it for instance if you have
sugar cravings instead of just saying no
to all sugary foods the idea is to
replace that with healthier options so
replace that with natural sugars from
fruits maple syrup or honey by doing so
you asked is satisfying your sugar
cravings but you are consciously making
healthier choices for your body so don't
worry about tomorrow or next year focus
on today the key is to make slow subtle
changes every single day and this will
allow time for your body and mind to
adapt the next point is to be hyper
aware of your environment it's easy not
to think of something or not to do
something if you don't see it or if
you're not around it so your environment
plays a crucial role in breaking your
bad habits if food is your weakness then
avoid buying and stocking up on junk
food this will reduce the chances of you
mindlessly grabbing something out of the
fridge and start binging if
try to quit smoking or drinking then
hanging out at a bar would not help okay
avoid places that would trigger you to
drink or smoke and if you're used to
drive thrus then change your route and
avoid driving through that same location
every day so take a look at how your
current environment is feeding your bad
habits
ask yourself what small changes can I do
right now step number six use habit
reminders have been reminders are a
great way to keep up with your new
routines the whole idea is to be hyper
aware especially when you're about to
fall back into your same old habits for
example when I tried to create biting my
nails I applied a nail polish because it
is absolutely disgusting to bite your
nails with nail polish on and it totally
worked and when I wanted to go to bed
earlier I set a daily reminder on my
phone at 11:00 p.m. to remind myself to
start winding down and if you have the
bad habit of eating mindlessly out of
your fridge then put a huge note on your
fridge to remind yourself to stop doing
it
these reminders might seem silly to
begin with but it's a great way for you
to be hyper aware of your habit change
the next step is to commit publicly when
you declare you goes publicly you are
more accountable in a way you have set a
challenge for yourself to succeed not
only to prove it to yourself but to
others which can be a huge motivation so
go ahead tell your friends tell your
family members join an online community
post your progress online and even leave
your comments below on my channel okay
don't just tell us once keep us updated
on a regular basis next be kind to
yourself you have probably gone through
the what the hell scenario so imagine
this oh my god I really want the ice
cream but you know what I'm just going
to not have it god I can't stop thinking
of the ice cream let me just have one
scoop what the hell let me just have two
scoops what the hell since I've ruined
my diet I matter so I just have the
entire top oh this tastes so good oh my
god what the hell I'm just going to
start again tomorrow and the end of the
day you feel absolutely shitty and
guilty and you repeated the entire cycle
over and over again and you ended up
consuming more can
then you initially plan to yes I do
believe that it is important to be
strict when it comes to eliminating bad
habits but you want to avoid filling
your head with negative thoughts
remember one mistake does not equal
failure okay so instead of beating
yourself up you have to learn to be kind
to yourself and forgive yourself this is
a process and it will take time
which leads on to my next point focus on
the process not just the results so stop
looking for shortcuts getting rid of a
bad habit is just like any long-term
goal it will take time and it wasn't
just happen overnight
it requires daily commitment reminders
and trial and error stick into just one
method might not work for you you might
have to try different methods until you
find something that works for you so it
is also very important for you to review
your progress on a daily basis
this might seem tough at first but if
you stick by it if you commit to it
eventually you will start to practice
the new habits without even realizing it
that's when you know you have succeeded
and the final step is to set a clear
goal and timeline just like anything you
want to achieve in your life you need to
set a clear goal and a realistic
timeline so let's do this together I
want you to stay committed and join me
on a 30-day habit change challenge okay
to begin with pick only one bad habit
and let that be your focus
what is your vet habit let me know in
the comments below and I want you to
just focus on that and eventually extend
the challenge to 60 or even 90 days I
encourage you to share your goal with
your family members and also close
friends and I want you to post a daily
picture of your progress tag me at
Joanna so official and hashtag 30 day
habit change challenge okay so be sure
to like this video share this video with
your friends and gather to join this
challenge and subscribe to my youtube
channel for new videos every Monday
Wednesday and Friday don't forget to
also turn on the notification button so
that you will get notified every time I
upload a new video all the best